معكم ملازم علا راجي خليل الجالودي انا
مرتب اداره السير بختم الشرطه النسائيه
[موسيقى]
اولها كان في صعوبه يقول لك انت بنت وكيف
تنزلي كيف اهلك برضوا بس امي ايش هي قالت
لي خليكي عرفتي انك انت بتشتغلي باخلاصك
وتحدي كل صعوبه بتحديها بالميدان اثبت
وجودك وهاي انا بثبت وجودي والشعار انا
لابسه والحمد لله اني فخر فيه وعزه اني
انا بخدم فيه مع زملائي مرتاحه انا نفسيه
انت حبيتي الشخصيه
[موسيقى]
مستاهله مش سهله انك تنزل على الميدان
وتعاملي مع مركبات وتعاملي مع الناس
بتاخذ ده يعني المراه تنزل هيك لا انا
تحديتها الصعوبه وحبيت انا اثبت وجودي
واداره يعني اعطيتني طاقه وراحه التعامل
مع الناس كيف يعني صار معي حادث اتعامل
معهم كيف تتعامل مع الحادث الي فيه بعيد
عنك
[موسيقى]
انا كنت على الدوار الداخليه كنت حامل
حامل انا يعني بطني جنين وانا بشتغل انا
مبسوطه ليش انا بحب شغلي بصراحه يعني
[موسيقى]